hachimachi that middle class famous tour
is in full swing gipperino you ain't
lying fatty it's a live comedy show we
play a little ayg with the crowd great
way to introduce people to the show
bring the squad come out and see us
we're coming baby yeah gang these
tickets are selling quickly uh so make
sure you get your tickets we're coming
in we're going to be red bank new jersey
then we're going to seattle portland all
in august then in september we're going
kansas city springfield st louis then
we're going down to nashville hitting
indy coming home to philly baby the
chicken's got to come home to roost yeah
then we're hitting providence rhode
island up there to bean town get those
tickets let's go welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage oh yeah a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they go to be classy
yeah they're just a big old piece of
trash
i'm your host jades foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here in
auntie's basement she's upstairs
sunbathing whoo she's got three weeks
booked that hedonism i'm trying to get
ready okay she goes for a long time no
tan lines get it in down there
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me slightly unamused this week
but what are you gonna do he is the ceo
of ru garbage he's an international
businessman he is the prince of park
avenue but always the king of the
boardwalk baby give it up for kj kevin
james ryan hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube as you know those numbers are
true [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh and then there was one more thing
www.patreon.com
are you garbage the greatest goddamn
website oh yeah ever created shout out
to the [ __ ] the yam and the kanti
families the two inventors of that
goddamn website love them [ __ ]
american heroes you are we just hit 5
000 patrons over there today going
camping this morning baby going
sign up get all the [ __ ] bonus
content over there it's a good time get
the bug spray and the bear spray we're
going out into the wild baby and having
a nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good he works the ones and twos
he crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
giving up her t-bone mcmuffin mr toby
mcmullen everybody what's up dudes what
up dog dude this has got to be the most
jack guy we've ever had i know dude he's
built like the [ __ ] gold gym logo
like the shield rope in here holy [ __ ]
gang we couldn't be [ __ ] more excited
to have our incredibly and i mean
incredibly special guests here with us
today for the first time you have seen
them on chrissy chaos you've seen them
on the adam ray podcast you've seen him
on the adam corolla podcast he's been on
ellen he went live on instagram with mr
mark zuckerberg you hear that
[ __ ] heard of him he's the co-host of
meme daddies but here's the real [ __ ]
turkey let me tell you right now look at
the numbers
his instagram page tank sinatra 3
million followers that's not then his
other page tanks good news 2.8 million
followers did that by accident
let's go
[ __ ] around and hit three milly no big
deal
his third instagram page influence in
the wild which is now a game that you
can get it is right here 4.9 million
followers let's see add those numbers up
you got the two that's a lot of [ __ ]
people yeah chances are you follow this
[ __ ] yeah ladies and gentlemen he is
an internet sensation he is the master
of the [ __ ] memes but the big
question about his mind today is he
garbage i need to tum to his face it
looks like he leads with a headbutt
give it up for tanks and archer
everybody i am irish i will lead with a
headphone
you got to be first move headbutt guy oh
yeah what's a boom
i mean just by nature it's not even uh
it's not my move but i could see it
happening
yeah it's in you you also have the vibes
of a guy who has someone in a headlock
while punching someone
you know
you're just like get the [ __ ] you're
just like
i'm good for two or three i need help
beyond that
yeah buddy thank you so much for coming
in man congratulations again here's the
game influencers in the wild check it
out check it the [ __ ] out very cool it's
going to be up there on the set
influencers in the wild the game thank
you go places gain followers get famous
no talent required look at that that's
the tag look at that
you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i love here the foley thing i've been
watching this podcast for a while this
thing you do here it reminds me of matt
foley i mean i don't know if you know oh
you do that i haven't picked up one do i
do that i haven't picked up no no this
you do this when you talk a lot you
[ __ ] you do the framing like a matt
foley i'm 35 years old okay i live in a
fan down the studio apartment
my girlfriend hates me anybody got blown
i can't get enough of it just the
emphasis on every joke is just boom
that's bad buddy i feel i feel myself
wanted to do it because in the
microphone and my shoulders are just
like i want to punch it
yeah i was doing push-ups in the car on
the way here i have a test car
i got a flatbed truck i have a tesla so
i just put it on autodrive and i was
doing push-ups in the back seat
chin up
elon was not happy
this kid's doing burpees in traffic what
we're talking about
so i know we're going to get to the ru
garbage questions later
to put myself ahead of the game a little
bit it comes with gifts and a brown
paper bag my kind of guy
forget the ribbon this better not be d
ball i'll tell you that right now listen
i i've been listening for a while okay
okay this is making me nervous i don't
know what this is
you were talking about sleeping with a
t-shirt
for a while
a sleep mask with a stain on it ladies
and gentlemen
a weighted sleep mat it came from amazon
i don't know where it was before that oh
that's very nice look at that you feel
that right doing the patreon episode
give me a snickers bar
he's not too far off i went i mean i'm
from among you so much so when i was
growing up in long island in the 90s 80s
right this was like the epitome of cool
if you had one of these you were just
[ __ ] crushing puss hit me
what the a zippy
i don't get you a gift with no batteries
so i got the [ __ ] ah
that's a fire hazard he can't be trusted
with flammable [ __ ] liquids this is
i'm gonna have to what buddy that's too
sweet you'll get this after you do your
homework okay i i was gonna get it
inscribed with the word garbage but i
didn't understand that
he didn't know what i was saying so i
just uh thank you that's sweet that's
very sweet
made in the usa huh zippo look at that
and i know it says it on the bottom
because a lot of the cheapos out there
don't say it i know you're off the cigs
so if you just if you want to crack open
this he's pulling out [ __ ] santa
claus i know i wanted to get myself some
points before with the questions rolling
no you don't need points i know uh i'm
from long island i'm from suffolk county
it's tough to come out of long island
not trash
very very hard i grew up on jericho
turnpike
in an easy pizza across the street from
chuck e cheese so stop you're giving it
away jesus christ
has you ever talked to the cops before
zip it will you i killed her i swear
it was a speeding ticket
say your seatbelt was undone
give us the full story then all right so
suffolk county long island new york give
us the story new york give us the back
story the origin story parents
catholic irish alcoholic cia family
catholic irish alcoholic
yeah yeah um
older sister younger sister
literally grew up
i mean there was a a chuck e cheese
across jericho turnpike for me my house
was right behind
what used to be called jeffrey's then
became
the new york sports club there was a gym
a gym yeah one thing he's just [ __ ]
born behind a gym yeah i was born they
were they were throwing out all the old
treadmills he was [ __ ] lifting him
over his head
converted into a crib
some little kid keeps stealing all the
kettlebells
that kid's going to be an animal
and
you know i was it was pretty normal my
father worked for the long island
railroad dad worked for long island rail
what'd your mom do
cleaned houses cleaned houses raised us
um so middle-class family 100 100
percent middle class single shout out to
middle class famous store of course
thank you very much now shows are
selling out
um
house
ranch
rancher a ranch yeah yeah one floor i
was born in a rancher as well three
bedrooms yellowstone what's going on
basement basement yeah just a normal
house with like was the basement redone
smoking in the house
who mom or dad both both mom and dad
pranking heaters every family ripping
haters all day what was the brand of
choice marlborough light
yeah
a gentleman when i see it
says that trashy
the marlboro miles in my house shout out
to the miles christmas gifts were bought
i mean we were going for the raft
in my house no one ever got that also
you wouldn't have the lung capacity to
[ __ ] get down the you know the river
yeah we i mean we had jackets we went
pretty heavy i had a marlboro miles
jacket like a red jacket damn that thing
was those things are coming back into
style now with all these young hipster
kids yeah you go into like a [ __ ]
thrift shop and they're like 800 bucks
to get a marble miles jacket oh they
cost thousands in actual cigarettes yeah
but then that's a perk you were buying a
bernie's anyway you know what i mean
yeah you were gonna you're gonna buy
them anyway i mean we we would be sent
around the corner to go buy cigarettes
and the uh lottery tickets and all that
[ __ ] and there was a bar around the
corner from my house and i used to go to
the bar
my mom cleaned the bar
what would you do you hanging out in the
bar hanging out with my parents yeah
just hanging just chilling in there yeah
yeah we'd play the the the thing
shuffleboard no not shuffleboard it was
like a
an arcade version of a shuffleboard but
there was wood shavings yeah in there
you'd throw the little wood i don't know
[Music]
that sawdust when you were a kid man
that might have all been fairy dust
that's that's just magic
it was magic the way that things slid
across the [ __ ] table so my mom
cleaned that bar okay found the dead
body in there one morning
come to find out later it's not like she
found a mouse dude no i mean it was like
uh it was a big deal huge deal yeah i
would assume it's a dead body
yeah yeah the guy just fell down the
stairs and like just kind of yeah he
can't really swiffer that away
we're out of pledge and there's a dead
guy at the bottom of the stairs who was
the guy um i don't remember but i
remember being in meetings later on
hearing a guy talk about the guy who
died did he live there did did the guy
live there or something no no no he just
like was there too late one night they
probably locked up the guy fell down the
stairs quietly or he was there no one
knew he was there yeah and then your mom
goes in to clean the house fine goes in
to clean it like 8 9 a.m the next
morning and she opens up the door and
she goes oh
whoa i'm gonna go home and call the cops
i would never step foot back do you
remember do you remember when she do you
remember this incident i remember when
she came home and she was upset about it
yeah i was pretty young i mean i but it
was definitely something i uh i logged
in the memory you're nagging her about
sugar cereal or something like that she
just saw [ __ ] corpse yeah i'm like
anyway we're at a lucky charm she's
sitting there with a [ __ ] marble like
four thousand
[ __ ] contemplating life yeah yeah
she's uh she i mean my parents smoked
heavily heavily yeah a lot of people did
back then man that was just the way
even non-smokers smoked at parties and
barbecues yeah no she wanted that oh
yeah i mean the stress level in my house
with my dad working for the railroad and
my mom trying to raise us we were very
close in age
my sister was two years older than me my
younger sister was a year and a half
younger than me that's irish right
triple check it out it was uh i i can
only imagine i have three children now i
have a 15 year old stepdaughter a
nine-year-old son and a four-year-old
son
if they were closer in age and all doing
the same [ __ ] all the time i don't know
i don't know what you know i can't
imagine what it would be
yeah parents were just [ __ ] built
different back then man they really were
i don't know they i think it was bad for
them oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah what do you think they just
kept their head down and [ __ ] just
found that body body it worked they just
smoked butts all day long just ripped
heaters yeah my my wife was when we had
our third son she's like i think i could
use some help like i would like some
sort of a nanny or something i was like
get out of here no one of my family's
ever had a goddamn my mom raised us all
alone and she did fine and then my next
thought was like maybe she didn't
maybe we should get you some help and
then we got some help and it was like
really helpful sure that's pretty classy
right there i'll tell you that we'll get
into that we'll get into that in a
little bit yeah i want to know more
about the ranch house now this basement
you're talking about was it finished
not for a while not for a long time did
was there a signing glass door that went
outside from that basement there was a
window like this
was there a door or was it open stairway
from the first floor down or was it like
no there was no it was an open stairway
that we all fell down yeah of course
yeah
i was born in a ranch house and i took a
[ __ ] header down that day
[ __ ] almost once a week and it was
the kind of stairs where you could you
couldn't just roll down it but you could
fall off the side yeah it was open yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that was like
that was like so the people who finished
the cement could get out that wasn't for
like to live in you know what i mean
they just made wooden stairs so they
could get out yeah bad news garage
garage was converted into a den for us
so there was also a step that everyone
spilled off of
all the time wait hold on i got a
picture of this so
the so you have a ranch house yep and
the garage was built onto the house yeah
it was part of the house so you walk in
the house i've never seen that that's
real trash i've seen it and then you
close it up
right like you didn't keep the big
garage door there no no yeah it was it
was bricked up it was like part of the
house okay yeah convert it into a deck
convert it into a dan danzer big out now
when did that happen is that was that as
far as back as you can remember i don't
remember that okay so my parents they
did some good work to the house they put
an extension on the house give my sister
a new one are they still in that house
they are yeah really yeah damn keeping
it old school yeah they stick around man
they're still there i mean the house is
the same pretty much they've done some
work interior wise to it the outside is
the exact same i mean it's a red brick
it's crazy it has a lawn looking
solid they keep it tight yeah they keep
it your dad kept it tight my dad i mean
he he was he also as in addition to
being a long island railroad engineer
worked for a landscaping company okay my
dad was a hard hard hard worker yeah man
but he retired at age 51. okay he's been
chilling ever since
good bennies at the long hour oh yeah
real good especially in that time period
yeah you you sign on and that was the
golden era of benny's dude yeah they
were they were just giving and giving
[ __ ] out oh yeah you moved the trade and
you got paid for a month
they were giving all those loans out to
vegas yeah [ __ ] money was rolling in
that's [ __ ] wild okay what was the
vacation like growing up yeah where'd
you guys go montauk
that's nice though mom talks nice mom
talks very shitty they're not shitty but
there is the affordable version of
mountain so we would go to a hotel
called the royal atlantic
we did it i'll say my parents did it
nice my parents with my aunts
on my mom's side cousins from michigan
and my my um friends of my mothers would
all come in
and we would get
four or five rooms in a row on the beach
okay and the day we would check out they
would book it for the next year so we
would go every year and it became a
really really solid tradition we did it
for probably 10 or 11 years that's a
good gig great memories there yeah great
memories instilled so far deep in my dna
that like if i go out there for fishing
which i'll do like a charter with a
friend of mine he'll have a spot and
i'll just jump on okay i still have to
go to fudge and stuff just to like take
pictures is sent to my cousins sure
chicken who are 50 years old yeah i like
that they'll go oh man remember it's
good old days man yeah it's very much
the same montauk has been well preserved
and the royal atlantic as far as hotels
go out there is about as good as it gets
it's central very centrally located the
rooms are you know beach rooms yeah yeah
yeah the royal atlantic has a pretty
nice ring to it i gotta tell you that
yeah but i mean but right across the
street you have the ronjo which has the
thing from greg brady's necklace when
he's in hawaii and he gets crushed by
the waves
huge out front
you know there's all the big big swing
of uh yeah accommodations out there i
gotcha [ __ ] neon lights everywhere
all right um
vacations
what was the high school mascot yeah it
was the high school mascot comac cougars
comec cougars all right it's very like
middle of the road yeah very 80s no that
sounds like it could be out of an 80s
teen movie when did you start working as
a kid
the first job i had was when i was 14
and i got fired from it after like three
days which was what
a bagel place
i worked at a bagel place and a friend
of mine worked at a a car wash next door
and that he came in that's very long
island the bagel place next to the
[ __ ] car
and i go uh i go yo i just just uh just
take that yoho i said just give me a car
wash i was 14. i didn't even have a car
then i can use i can trade that car wash
for something else and trade that i was
trying to trade a pin into a house
that's what got you fired was a [ __ ]
you yeah and this woman
who i still have a little bit of a
resentment against but she's obviously
there's something wrong with you
over it 45 years old working in a bagel
place not that there's anything wrong
with that but she was something was off
with her you probably shouldn't probably
shouldn't say your name yeah it was 14
years old yeah what the [ __ ] but still
you're the new guy you can't be trusted
you're coming into your third day you're
stealing you're moving you who's out the
back door for you you're watching it
yeah one you who can't be trusted and i
heard i saw her pull the guy uh saw
aside the owner and he pulls me into the
back and he goes and this was a pretty
good lesson for me because i didn't
really know how business worked i just
thought
everything was free for you you own the
place so he goes
i heard that you gave a friend of yours
a drink for free so you did steal from
us so i can't have you working here
anymore i was like steal from you what
do you mean he's like
you can't work here anymore right all
right so i went and got a job across the
street grabbed a couple of you's on the
way out the door
shaking them throwing them um i got a
job at music den across the street which
was a music store and that i kept for
like a year now is this we talking this
is like a strip mall right this is like
a long island strip mall
this is a weird area of the
town i'm talking about because you got
jericho turnpike which splits into uh
vets highway and it's like a massive and
in the middle of that you have a world
war ii
gun that's like 10 feet high that's
exactly what you're talking about you
have to you have to you go around it
right it's huge yes yeah so right there
like
when i say across the street i mean like
500 yards
as the crow flies across the street you
know what i mean
huge disparity but i was still in the
same area
so i worked at music then which i loved
because i'm a music fanatic okay and i
worked there for about a year i've had
62 jobs in my life damn i've had a lot
of jobs
let's talk about bespoke post baby you
mean box of awesome hey get a box
awesome gang you want to take your
summer adventures up to the next level
just do it with a flamethrower huh
you want it they got it baby they got
cool stuff man they got drink mixers
they got pocket knives they got ted they
got cool guy stuff that you're going to
look cool when you're whipping out you
want to show up to the beach family okay
show it to the beach family vacation you
won't look cool boom they'll take care
of you going camping boom they'll take
care of you travel boom they take care
of you yeah they sent us a bunch of
stuff we just got new stuff new camping
gear we're i'm taking it on i was going
to break it i was taking it out on
a camping trip i got a cool new knife
it's like the outsiders shutting up
cutting up kindling um to get started
just take the quiz at box of awesome.com
your answers will help them pick the
right box of awesome for you they
release new boxes every month across a
ton of different categories each box is
valued at around 70 70 but you only pay
a fraction of that fraction plus you're
helping support small business 90 of
everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small up-and-coming
brand it's free to sign up you can skip
a month at any time or cancel this is it
baby here's the turkey get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
box of awesome.com enter the code
garbage at checkout that's box of
awesome dot com code garbage for twenty
percent off your first box
boxingwilson.com go garbage do it now a
word from our sponsor better help guys
mental health is very important if your
car was broken what would you do would
you just keep driving around no you
would figure it out if you have a flat
tire you'll fix it if your roof is
leaking you'll take care of it a lot of
times you turn to a trained professional
when it comes to mental health nothing
is different you need the help of a
trained professional a lot of times and
better help is here to help you
i know for me talk therapy has helped me
a lot in my comedy career in my journey
and all figuring out what i want to do
in my life get if you're stuck it's not
you got to take the stigma away from it
baby a lot of people need help it's easy
peasy whether you're going through a
breakup you lost your job you're trying
to switch jobs whatever it is better
help can assist you wherever you are at
this point in your life it's online
therapy it offers video phone and even
live chat therapy sessions so you don't
have to see anybody if you don't want to
i recommend you do because it kind of
helps but if you're just getting your
feet wet just trying to figure it out
start with just uh you know some text or
something figure it out start texting
them sliding those dms of better help
you'll be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours which i've said over and
over again is very important it's very
hard to find somebody you call you wait
for them to call you back it's a whole
issue but better help solves that in
under 48 hours
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and our listeners get ten
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com
garbage that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-dot-com
garbage do it so what was the weird if
you have to say what was the weirdest
one besides me maker i suppose
the weirdest one i mean the one that
that throws everyone for a loop is that
i worked as a dancer at bar mitzvahs for
a long time but that was a [ __ ] great
gig even in the suburbs of philly that
was like he's a dancer for barry
rothsteiner what does that exactly
entail i've never heard of this really
like a stripper
no no no no no
so like you know the production company
whoever's putting the dj whatever would
go on and it would bring
all right at this time i'd like to
welcome everybody to todd's bar mitzvah
and uh
welcome to the dance floor we've got
george uh with you know he's gonna do
some i was the only white guy in the
tri-state area that could break that so
i was in heavy demands
heavy demand and uh and i got paid
really well for very little work i need
to go out and just get the party started
yeah you got to think there's a lot of
introverted young teens who are whatever
they they go they get the [ __ ] house
there's always guys and girls i would
have hated you i would have never gotten
out there you ever meet a 13 year old
jewish kid from long island
and not exactly not the life of the
party no no so we would get them going
but then we'd also dance with the old
ladies okay we'd go hang out and have
we'd be like uh ringers at a party
that's [ __ ] wild i don't ever
remember and i worked for like
eight or nine different companies and i
worked my way up i mean some of these
companies they would pay you
good money for like a four hour party
sure you'd wear black on black because
you'd sweat like an apple and how old
are you
when you're doing this i started when i
was 20
i did one last saturday
can't beat it
under the table what do you want yeah no
i started when i was 18. i was at a
friend of mine's graduation party and i
was ripping it up i mean just tearing up
i like the way you move tearing up the
deck some slime welcomes up the
afternoon listen the way you did the
worm when everybody else was eaten blew
my mind yeah i wormed my way over to the
art to the buffet table can you do the
robot like that every saturday
or is this just a fluke
there's just a man of chevits in you
what's this so i got a job with this
company mikey mike productions yeah yeah
very long thing ever mikey mike
productions and limousine services
and he i mean he got i mean some of
these companies it's like like um
jay-z started off as a drug long island
is a complete other [ __ ] world it
really otherwise i like how you're
comparing mikey mike when jay-z started
well like
i don't know monkey mike i'm sure he's a
great guy but he's no hope all right
listen jay-z took a a
an illegitimate business and turned it
into an empire because he had a great
business mind ceo's mind that marketing
plan was me 100
just listen that song on the way in
mikey mike i'm not comparing him to
jay-z actually he was kind of the worst
but
he took it and made it into this
massive business probably cleaned up he
started off with djs
then he started hiring dancers then he
started hiring mcs then he started
hiring other talent then he started
renting furniture then he started buying
lights then he started buying other [ __ ]
and
huge productions people like furniture
for a party not like just like couches
and [ __ ] right no furniture for a party
where you're having a lazy boy if you
need me
tank hit him with the worm
i'm gonna pull in to pull out couches
everyone on long island knows i was the
first guy to bring a strobe light to a
bar
yeah
that's awesome it gets crazy you start i
mean before you know it it's like when i
was working for tom kaufman productions
right we did a a bar mitzvah
at the [ __ ] he also says tom goffman
like we should know what that is well no
some people may so it's just a dc of
course it's just it's a aka what do you
think tkp it's a funny name
ours was beach street beat street
productions
that guy used to bobby morgenstein or
something yo he used to kill it so we
did a bar mitzvah at the waldorf astoria
there you go
this bar mitzvah how much do you think
it cost dude 200 grand 2.4 million
dollars jesus christ this bar mitzvah
cost that's going to be our next patreon
go get a bar mitzvah for the big mac oh
man i love the game i was so jealous of
those kids the jew my jewish friends
their parents would go all the [ __ ] out
i never saw a dancer though i mean they
would have uh
that's because we were incognito you
didn't know we were it was also probably
it was played hold up your time wait a
minute you were incognito
it wasn't no we wouldn't go out and
dance in front of you and for you you
were probably
just hanging out with your friends and
we were getting the other people who
were people like who invited this guy
yeah bro but you were 13 you were
probably
in your own world you know what i mean
you're [ __ ] you know all googling out
over this [ __ ] hunk doing the worm
what are you talking about yeah slip off
my chair right now thinking about it i'm
worried about who invited this guy he's
[ __ ] the life of the party i want him
at the next party you probably thought i
was an uncle i was gonna get his number
hey milstein your cousin can really move
[Laughter]
your jacked irish cousin can really move
dude
he's a jew
on his mother's side his mother's side
he's got a good hand the good hand
you're eating two slices of pizza at
once [ __ ] shaking it up on a dance
floor
oh my god i gotta hide your crucifix
necklace
yeah that's the weirdest uh that's the
weirdest job i've ever had i think i
don't know i've had so many beautiful
man long island is [ __ ] something
else it's great uh were you allowed to
eat in your room as a kid
my parents paid attention they may have
known that i was [ __ ]
crushing subways in my bed
at 10 p.m every night
i ate in the middle of the night every
night were you a fat kid oh yeah is that
how the obviously the the turn yeah it
was made fun of and and uh
bullied to an extent but
you know i had this problem and i still
have this problem just not to the extent
that i did
when i started lifting weights
yeah the summer before ninth grade
something happened where my appetite
just became
voracious
the worst there's there's three things
that i've done in the middle of the
night that i can't believe i've done
one of them is drink an entire bottle of
maple syrup
[Laughter]
that was when it was
out of the bottle or a glass out of the
bottle
on the rocks or what are you doing
wait why was that up or what i was
eating peanut butter so my grit that
doesn't make it better
i should have said waffles
i was having a salad and wait how old
are you when this happened 15. you're 15
years old 15. you're a bigger kid i'm
240. okay you're eating peanut butter in
your room in the middle of the night no
in the kitchen you're in the kitchen
just eating peanut butter so my chunky
or creamy creamy okay yeah yeah all
right i'm not a total dirtbag okay so so
my mother's my mother's father my
grandfather taught us this snack which
don't even bother trying it because it
will ruin your [ __ ] life okay but i'm
gonna tell you what it is but don't do
it because
i'm telling you it's gonna cause
major problems
so you mix together syrup and peanut
butter
and you eat it on saltine crackers
okay maple syrup and peanut butter okay
it's like being sweet yeah
but
something else too something else
happens god intervenes
and creates this
i i can't even describe it
so anyway i had this in my brain since i
was a kid so i would mix peanut butter
and maple syrup whenever i could
so i just was eating peanut butter
making sandwiches putting syrup on the
[ __ ] sandwich closing it
taking a bite of the sandwich squeezing
syrup in my mouth
crunching it all around i can see how
you got it i didn't drink it straight it
was like oh my god i squeezed it and it
went it like went like the ketchup
sure and i was like oh my god it's over
it's done i can't believe i [ __ ]
finished a whole bottle of maple syrup
damn so that was the first one that was
really like i i i have a problem um the
second one was when because i'm i'm like
grayed out i'm half asleep half awake
when i do this stuff okay
the second one was when i was living
alone for the first time i was 25 years
old and um
i don't know i i must have thought i was
making oatmeal or something in the
middle of the night
i put a jar of peanut butter in the
microwave
put my dick in put put it on
and then drank it
and almost killed myself
with the oil hot oil oh yeah going down
my throat
yeah it was like i mean guava in my
throat what the [ __ ] i mean i almost die
i i legitimately thought okay this is it
for me
you know it wasn't a ton it was maybe
like two three four tablespoons or
whatever but it was enough to like coat
my throat go into my stomach i was like
oh my god i almost woke my roommate up
and told him like just watch me for the
next 15 minutes because i think i might
be
i might be dying right now i microwaved
it for like a minute that's a long time
wild if you see me grabbing jar and
jelly knock me out
call the cops
and then the third thing
is
um i got into quest bars and peanut
butter and coke zero for a while in the
middle of the night dude
peanut butter
zero i had a big power bar uh
[ __ ] phase where i like them more
than regular candy bars because of the
chew in them yeah there's a lot there's
a mouthfeel situation man
yeah we used to get the whole box of
them my mom would get which which the
actual power bar power bar chalk butter
oh chocolate yeah
i'd like the peanut butter too but just
unwrapping those those chocolate ones
and like bending them up
it's like taffy dude like literally like
[ __ ] taffy yeah i prefer a long time
i preferred it over a candy bar of
course i might probably be like what the
[ __ ] eat a half a box of them your jaw
starts hurting oh they're not even rock
climbing tonight
i put powder on my hands
got caribbean here yeah
i wasn't working out at all
but god do you need all this power for
so you got into coke zero so yeah one
night i um
for some reason took the the knife took
a a giant thing of of peanut butter like
a a mound mm-hmm are you fat at this
point at 25 are you no i'm just you know
this this is me making up for the
when i wake up in the middle of the
night i am the fat kid that is still
there from when i was a kid okay kid
when i wake up so i eat and i eat as
well as i can during the day and then at
night i'm like
mom's not here it's when the monster
comes in you know yeah so the middle of
the day do you still do this is this
still happening sometimes not as often
and not to the extent right but
sometimes you just wake up in the middle
and like starve and you go into the
kitchen and look out starving um
but one night i took a peanut butter jar
spread it i spread the peanut butter for
some reason on the can of coke zero
and then this guy's bonkers
and then wiped it off with the quest bar
ate it and then threw the can of coke
zero on the counter and went back to bed
and my wife woke up this was like five
or six years ago
she woke up and she was like like i
don't drink right but if i did i imagine
this is what it would be like the next
morning after a blackout sure she was
like legitimately upset thinking that
you drank no no she was like
something happened what's going on she
goes what happened a little high strung
he goes what happened last night i go
what do you mean she goes
i woke up and there was a coke zero can
covered in peanut butter stuck to the
counter
and i was like
oh yeah i do remember that kind of
mm-hmm i don't know why i did that
though she's like
this has got to stop that's wild
it was like a moment for us
yeah it was a real she was upset with me
but that's not me
i'm not that person i wanted to say to
her like that's not when i wake up
that's a difference maybe that's really
who you are i would have said somebody
broke in and did some weird [ __ ] yeah i
should have i don't know i wasn't
thinking
holy [ __ ] it's cloudy from the coke zero
all right
that ascertain or whatever let's get
into some ayg questions yeah let's do
some cues here [ __ ] get into thinking
you've given us enough backstory hey
i mean you're gonna need a lot to pull
you out of what you already laid
although the zippo is very nice yeah i
appreciate it thank you i was gonna get
you one with like something real trashy
on it like a like a deck of cards or
something david yeah no there was like a
poker it's like a poker thing but i
figured keep it clean keep it simple
that's beautiful it's beautiful i don't
know how that's gonna help you with the
coke zero can yeah but we're gonna see
were you a crystal light family growing
up
we did do crystal light did crystal
light what would you have with dinner
so there's one
this this may explain the coke zero
thing there's one night in particular i
remember waking up from a nap and having
a plate of spaghetti like a [ __ ]
werewolf what the [ __ ]
there's mayonnaise in my hair [ __ ]
waking up in the middle of the night
terrorizing the town of jericho
one night i woke up i went to bed with
six feet of bubble tape in my mouth
remember this the bubble tape yeah i i
took the whole thing in my mouth
i don't think there was six feet it was
three feet yeah there was no six feet
next to three bro
might be six six feet of bubble tape for
you not them i remember the commercial
so i looked at the heart
can't wait for my bubble tea
so i put it all in my mouth one night
over the course of two hours of watching
tv then fell asleep with it in my mouth
and toddler and woke up with it in my
head in my hair and my parents had to
shave my head at like 3 a.m
yeah oh damn wait i did it in the middle
of the night at like 3 a.m they were
dying my parents i had a purple helmet
on with like hair sticking through the
the gum
oh it was the purple bubble tape too
rape yeah yeah sorry man that catch that
water's back here yeah that gets the
gels going that [ __ ] was awesome oh man
the first seven bites there sucked but
it got around to it bubble team hit the
scene like a [ __ ] rapping wrecking
ball man you could [ __ ] big league
choose see ya bubble tapes yeah no [ __ ]
i was always i was an athlete so i was a
big league joker
i was a [ __ ] cleanup bidder
i was an athlete on and off to [ __ ]
bigly chew had so much sugar in it that
for the first couple of chews it was
like it was like two it was you chewed
too fast
it really took a while to tighten up
yeah it was too soft
yeah it was like yeah it wasn't it
wasn't gum cane you had to get it to the
gum yeah it was wild man
oh my god all right what the [ __ ] oh
wait so so the spaghetti the coke and i
remember taking a sip of the coke and it
was like ecstasy i've been chasing that
high everything 100 yeah so you you were
you were was it regular coca-cola that
was a cocktail that was coca-cola okay
so your parents would give you soda with
dinner yeah long island and if you went
out if you went out to dinner with your
family
would you be allowed more than one soda
i was at one soda and that's it you know
what i don't remember
ever going out to dinner with my family
just on the spot thinking about it i i
don't remember ever doing that did
brandy serve food
the bar
i don't think so oh man i we went to
like long island railroad dinner dances
and [ __ ] is that
it's a dinner and a dance bro
employees yeah yeah they have like you
said it like i got invited
they'd have events and like sure you
know what i mean um but i bet you the
food at those things was probably
[ __ ] all [ __ ] up
meatballs mashed potatoes swedish
[Music]
but going out later on with my family
um
after i was of drinking age before i got
sober i do remember drinking quite a bit
and nobody ever said hey don't drink it
like my mom would say hey have two i'd
be like hurry at eight what are you
talking about you know same with our
family it's like yeah it's how much you
can drink like there's
yeah there was no limit on drinking
because it was like hey the more you
drink the more i can drink [ __ ] put them
away yeah yeah of course
making me look good hey gang let's talk
about helix mattresses baby the best in
the biz i sleep on one every goddamn
night of my life and it's the best
decision i ever made the good folks at
heals were nice enough to send me and my
lady friend my wife
uh a mattress
we took the two minute sleep quiz two
minutes you who doesn't have two minutes
go find out what you're matched with and
ask you what you like how you sleep the
whole nine yards and figures out what
mattress is best for you we were matched
with the twilight series and we loved it
we loved it so much we upgraded to a
king and now it's me the bird and hanzi
ponzi all sleep in the helix mattress
it's fantastic no going to a mattress
store talking to some salesman who
doesn't know what he's doing he's
working on commission he always goes
right to you baby find out what you want
and they got every matches you could
ever imagine for plus size guys if you
sleep hot if you sleep cold if you like
it firm if you like it soft whatever you
want helix has it covered if you're
sleeping on a mattress that your nana
died in it's time to get a new mattress
and helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners go to helixsleep.com
garbage with helix better sleep starts
now
do it have you ever taken a bath in a
hotel
yes
dude
what a nice hotel doesn't matter is that
trash a bath and a hotel
if it's like the waldorf or something
like that and you're in the gym
was it after the glick stein's [ __ ]
bar bar mitzvah
no but you know what um
i got invited down to the soho beach
house in miami okay to go speak there
and they had a bath
and my wife was staying downstairs i can
only handle like an hour and a half of
sun two hours of sun max
and there was a bath there and for some
reason i was like kevin in home alone
and i and i put so much soap in it this
was like three years ago
was this because you were sunburned was
this like medicinal or you're like i'm
just having a day i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm
drawing a nice bath i would never do
this in my house because i don't feel
like cleaning up or i don't have bubble
bath in my house
um but yeah i went i mean there was the
bubbles were
three
four feet tall i mean it was comical was
this at night or during the day during
the day that's weird it was weird yeah
you're taking it back as a guy who likes
a nice bath a bath during the day
if i was your wife i would have more
questions about that than the [ __ ]
no i made sure it was done by the time
she got home if i got caught doing that
i would have been embarrassed
to watch the day away you let it all get
off of you you relax holy [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] yeah i'm sorry it's like taking
a sleeping pill
at lunchtime he apologized i'm sorry
have you ever had a hot dog in a
hamburger roll
oh yeah i've had a hot dog on uh white
bread yeah of course yeah i'm from
coleman have you ever had a hamburger
and a hot dog roll have i um
chop it in half that's a good time i'm
sure
my dad used to eat uh hamburgers on
english muffins which i did real classy
breakfast burgers that's real classy
yeah there's a lot i don't know if it's
real
it is because all all the night all the
nice irish joints on the upper east side
uh when i was banging up there back in
the nazi [ __ ] by the way the nicer
irish places they all did [ __ ]
burgers on english muffins and i always
thought that was real it's an
interesting comment because i couldn't
afford martin's potatoes yeah
um can you name any of the boats on
deadliest catch
no
did you keep your butter on the counter
as a kid we kept it out of the fridge
man yeah you did yeah i mean we would go
through a stick a day we were awesome
we got all kind of butter all those cans
of soda
can't be waiting for it to [ __ ] fall
out no as a matter of fact if we went
through a stick and the butter had to
come out of the fridge it was like a
problem we would be pissed and we'd
microwave it and then we'd like it would
be like liquid yeah and we'd scrape it
off the top and then it would be like a
canoe yeah water you know what i mean
it's a real delicate the [ __ ] the
timing of trying to defrost butter in
the microwave is a [ __ ] science eight
and a half seconds maybe yeah same thing
as a quest bar yes wait you put those in
the microwave oh yeah oh this guy's
crazy yeah i talked about taking beds in
the middle of the day
this guy's not [ __ ] safe
you were any member of your family ever
a lifeguard
no okay but i did work at the town pool
in huntington as a uh ticket taker
okay
okay
yeah
you know you're uber rating
i know it roundabout
solid yeah it's pretty good it's like
4.9 something but i don't take a ton of
ubers so
drive or lift i drive just drive i drive
where you live at now where's the
where's the island smith town you're
okay so you're out on the island suffolk
county okay shout out to smithtown water
that's a deep cut smithtown's really
nice you know about that no i just know
it's from uh chrissy d and yani always
talks that's from my episode oh is it
yeah yeah i skipped that one just
kidding
smithdown water department
okay look at that all right i was
educated i was educating them on the
difference between waters
and then i said you know the
there's probably one person watching all
of smithtown water right now and either
chris or giannis goes i don't think
we've ever had somebody on the podcast
give a shout out to the smithtown water
department
shout out to vinnie over there
i wanted to do this podcast a because i
love you guys thank you thank you buddy
i love the podcast
um i love comedy so much it's been my
favorite comedy and music are my two
favorite things since i was five six
years old
but also because um
i think that what you guys do is so fun
finding out if people are garbage
and i wanted to know from the experts
because i do think some things that are
class
but i also have i'm still waiting
you got about 20 minutes left so you
better start making a case for you well
i brought you gifts
but i've had a correct governor
and i'm pretty sure a huge sleep match
you're trying to pay us off
at a board game you have an ownership
but but i've had a whole sure i'm going
to get a venmo request for later
maybe i am garbage
what
are you kidding me
talking about growing up on the turnpike
and what does that have to do with the
water what are you talking about if i go
to your house right now what kind of
when i ask for water what am i getting
tap but i have a whole house filter on
which is alkaline water
i'll give you that through the whole
house that's pretty close we shower in
[ __ ] fiji level one you know what i
mean
i'll be showering
shout out to aquafina huh
taking a bath in club soda that's great
just out of the gun from brandy's
you die
we're gonna get into now a little bit i
would assume that you're doing something
you're doing very well obviously okay
great point yeah i grew up dressed of
course okay still in you dude i don't
know why i don't think i mean you can
get all the house [ __ ] filters you
want
there's no way
i wasn't sweating i bet you that wasn't
cheap though getting that water system
hooked up at the house no did you buy it
did you build a house or buy an old
house or what do you what no we bought a
house
yeah i'm not i don't have the patience
to uh go through that process i can i
can't do that hmm ever seen a fight at a
waffle house
no i never been to a waffle house have
you been in a brawl
yeah yeah yeah
we're at yeah i'm not a big fighter to
be honest with you but i did get into a
fight you don't come out of [ __ ] long
island without ever getting in a [ __ ]
scrum you know
yeah i got into a fight outside of a
deli once in my senior year of high
school
um
it's a rite of passage
that was your graduation project
go tune someone up in a parking lot
there was a there was a fight between
comac and northport the night before at
a basketball game nice and i ran across
town rivalry yeah komack and northward
had a big rivalry for some reason i
guess because stupid heist
yeah
northport was worse but uh i have to say
that legally each team was like three
and ten yeah it was terrible still
fighting but i i recognized the car from
the the fight the night before what was
it do you remember what kind of car yeah
it was a mustang with rims on it yeah it
was yeah
it wasn't a beamer it wasn't a minivan
and uh and i
felt i was in this pizza place and like
20 kids walked in and i'm very stupid
for not putting two and two together but
i saw these kids walk in and they were
like looking around and i was like oh
these kids are looking for trouble i
just like instinctively knew it and then
then i walked outside and i saw the car
from the night before and i said to my
friends yo that's the car from the night
before and it did not occur to me at all
that those 20 kids might be with that
car sure so we waited by the car and
then all of a sudden the 20 kids come
out and it's just me and two of my
friends
it's 5-0 what's the deal and i still
started a fight with him nice for no and
this is like so unlike me because
usually i'll try and talk or reason or
just like break dance your way out of it
[ __ ] it
see this
like that
spinning on your head kicking nine guys
in the face
yeah real zoolander [ __ ] zouander hadn't
come out yet i didn't know that was an
option
so i'm 240 in high school shaved head
look crazy right
so
i i go hey maple syrup i go who's whose
car is this yeah i smelled like a tree
[Laughter]
and he goes it's mine why i go you were
at the comac high school game basketball
game last night and he goes yeah i go
something something and then he's like
hey this isn't your problem we know who
we're looking for it's not you
and he goes
and he goes tell your friend to come
back here tomorrow at 12 30. and i for
some reason
i look at all of them and i go you're
all [ __ ] dead like that
so unlike me real movie lion and then
one kid comes up and goes this guy pops
out
your meatballs meatball slugs ready
now as soon as i finish this sandwich
some guy who was about my size goes
let's [ __ ] go right now so we started
fighting and then another kid jumped on
top of me then my friend took him off
and then it was probably like five on
two for a little while but then everyone
i mean fights got so fast yeah i got so
tired it felt like i was fighting for
like eight hours dude eight second fight
will put me on the bench
this fight went on for like months two
minutes yeah that's crazy it was too
late that's an eternity i threw up it
was a nightmare
yeah so in the second round i thought i
had them
yeah you had all that pizza in you you
don't fight after the slices three
slices yeah
yeah it was a special i had two specials
it was a nightmare oh my god so that's
my big fight that's beautiful man have
you ever worn a hoodie with a thumb
sleeve or a thumb hole
no okay
anybody in your family ever see a ufo
claim to see the ufo
like how they wouldn't even tell if they
uh do you open your eyes under water
this guy dragged all right was there an
extended period of time where you walked
around with a gallon jug of water oh
yeah i was the [ __ ] i
[Laughter]
i was doing that in 1998.
i used to drink two three gallons of
water a day that's how i lost all my
weight in my senior i lost like 60
pounds
i was [ __ ] i saw anna nicole smith
on tv when she lost all her weight she
was probably also doing cocaine but the
interview she was big on fen fan or
whatever wasn't she yeah the interview
she gave this is what's this is why i
remember it because she goes they go how
did you lose all the weight she goes oh
i just drank so much water and when i
couldn't drink any more water i just
hold my nose and i remember thinking
water doesn't have any smell why are you
holding your nose but then i just drank
more water and i looked at my dad i'm
like does water make you lose weight and
he goes if you drink enough of it yeah
it fills you up it hydrates you and you
know it's the best thing you can do and
i drank like four glasses of water that
night and then i drank a gallon of water
a day for the next two years that's
awesome yeah
anyone in your family refer to the
bathroom as the john the commode or the
lou
no but i think the commode is probably
the worst of those three yeah it makes
my [ __ ] skin crawl have you any
member of your family ever been injured
at an amusement park
no
i don't think so
you said your big drive do you i assume
you have an easy pass in the car oh yeah
is it mounted or do you have to hold it
it's mounted but i will hold it if i'm a
holder
[Laughter]
she doesn't have the mount
so the the every time we approach it's a
fire drill yeah but it'll pick it up in
the car anywhere doesn't matter yeah
still panic i know me too
um let me ask you this
oh my god i gotta have a lot mine's
propped up behind the like the dashboard
screen
and anytime i take a hard turn or i get
up on a highway
let me ask you this so you don't you
have your own home let's say your trash
cans are out front yeah somebody walks
by and throws something in your trash
can how do you feel about that go for it
you're okay with that that's a big
problem in my head really i don't even
like doing it to other people because i
know i would not like that but see i
think it's are the trash cans empty or
the trash cans full
whatever no because if they're empty now
i have to take your trash into my garage
if the trash it if they already came to
pick up the trash
okay i understand
yeah i understand someone throws trash
into my empty trash can but would you
rather just throw it on the front lawn
i'd rather you [ __ ] find a proper
disposal receptacle for it hold it yeah
i think that is so now i'm taking your
trash into my garage that's no
what tank i'll believe in this guy what
do you think this guy's suspect well
i'll tell you what i don't want to
in my old house i had a tree that that
um
the one that we moved out of i had a
tree that
kept on my trash kind of went over like
dropped leaves on my neighbor's property
that might as that's a [ __ ] act of
war in the suburbs and he was nuts he
was a retired police officer
unmarried no girlfriend no kids no
nothing he would just meticulously
manicure his property all day long and
it was a small property okay like every
blade of grass was the perfect length
like not a nothing out of sight
out of line
so the tree was a problem so he used to
rake his leaves every day and he would
take
in his mind whatever he thought
fell from my tree
and put the bag on my property to say
you take care of this yeah it was in a
bag it wasn't like he would just throw
it but it was still odd right yeah and i
remember saying to my wife i'm like yo
this guy
puts
his version of whatever fell off our
tree onto our property in a bag isn't
that weird
so i i did say to her one time i said
listen on a scale of one to ten
how much does the presence of the bag
bother you
the actual bag itself
devoid of the contact she goes
i don't know do
i said yeah but how much does it bother
you that he thinks it's okay to do that
she's like oh 10. i'm like yeah it's a
10 for me too right so then i decided i
was going to say something to him and
then i was like what's the best case
scenario i make the guy feel bad and
weird and then i have to have that thing
over us the whole and then he wound up
moving so yeah huh god help you you
really got to pick and choose but i
would have cut the tree down i did yeah
well it was a huge tree anyway yeah but
he was out there blowing the blowing the
shavings away while they were cutting
the tree down
that was out of his mind psycho yeah
what a psycho
uh let's see we use a refillable uh
water bottle station at the airport
i don't think so are you flying first
class usually now i am yeah yeah yeah
okay mean business take your shoes off
on the couch
[Laughter]
yeah does aunt titty know i'm here or no
i don't know
she's upstairs working on memes
um do i take my shoes off no i don't
even take my shoes off at home
i like my feet covered wow wait a minute
hold on really you walk in the house
you're leaving today you get back to the
house yeah you don't take your shoes
walk right in with the shoes on walk
right in with the shoes on i'll nap in
my bed with these shoes on what i don't
give a [ __ ] you'll lay down in your bed
i i for under the cover no no no no no
no no i had to check with you but still
even still man
your wife doesn't freaking get it no
that you're in bed you're in the bed
with shoes on i don't always it's not a
practice but like i don't believe
there's no line for me between
inside outside like it's all the same
[ __ ] we cannot live together i there's
distinct lines
does your wife do that
no she's like a barefoot person you have
inside clothes and outside clothes sure
yeah there was a girl that i worked with
that yeah i'm out all day in new york's
in new york city and i go home i'm not
like sitting on my couch in the clothes
i wore for 10 hours why are you leaning
against buildings all day or yeah sure i
mean it's it's mostly a practice of when
i was taking the subway all the time now
i got a couple of them i think you're
both crazy to be honest with you well
you wear the same clothes every day so
what are you gonna say but sleep getting
in bed with your shoes on that that's
wild i understand i'm on the other end
of it like i don't do it all the time
but i i have a thing in my head that i
believe that a nap is not a nap unless
you are wearing the clothes that you've
been wearing all day and you have pants
and shoes on otherwise you just went to
bed at a weird time
man that's a real weird like my wife
naps under the covers i kind of back it
yeah you're also nuts
no you can take a nap under the covers
no you can't you just went to bed at a
weird time
no yeah that's a nap a nap is going to
bed is there a gas leak in here or
something
everybody's going crazy
no i [ __ ] with it
a nap isn't a nap unless you got jeans
on
i imagine the bedding's real nice you
got the king-sized mattress i would
assume yeah
the whole nine yards they'll be like so
crazy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's classic i like that you feel that
thing on your eyelids oh it's great you
sleep you use one
oh yeah you do my wife has one and i'll
use it when i take an i guess that
that's way against you're taking it do
you put a sleep mask on to take a nap no
this guy doesn't like jewelry or being
comfortable this is nuts yeah i love
comfort you have a ceiling fan over the
bed shoes
yes you do bro i mean
are all the light bulbs in it
um are they all working i don't know if
this one does this one doesn't even have
light bulbs you got a remote
no it's the switch okay yeah but i saw
this video on tick tock of uh have you
guys seen interstellar no
you haven't seen the matthew mcconaughey
movie yeah yeah of course christopher
nolan right oh it's my second favorite
movie of all time great movie first
obviously is i heart huckabees
but um
there's a scene
smooth move faster we don't have time
[Laughter]
david or russell makes a fine film yeah
huckabee is why the nutty professor why
i can't do stand-up comedy but that's
we'll get it that's a whole other thing
i've tried stand-up i can't do it i
can't tell the same joke over and over
again i feel like uh jude law at the in
that movie when he throws up but um
so
there's a tick tock where this guy is uh
he he's seeing himself put on a fan for
the first time and matthew mcconaughey's
like no
no and he it's him leaving his daughter
like he's trying to get himself not to
leave i put a fan on
six months ago and um
my wife got up to leave early for work
one day she was super early and i was
still sleeping and she turned the fan
off and i felt like i woke up in hell
yeah yeah oh that's the worst waking up
somebody kills the ac while you're
sleeping or something like that oh my
god wake up i'd rather i'd rather wake
up i did today from it being too cold
like it was too cold you gotta be too
cold i know but like the coldness woke
me up because i only had a sheet so i
was like [ __ ] proper freezing the air
i'd rather wake up like that than wake
up sweating the air's got to be moving
yeah you're also sleeping in the north
face probably pretty hot too
but here i am in my parka you know take
the snow cap off you'll be all right no
i understand i can't sleep in stagnant
air yeah at all something's got to be
moving around even if i'm covered i mean
i'm covered by the blanket i got to feel
something on my cold is
half the fun
you get dressed in front of the dryer
no you have a get dressed proper
upstairs all that stuff yeah okay do you
use scented trash bags
no we have uh we have one of those
compactors weird no it's a um
one of those we have like our trash bags
our style cue simple human
one of those things my my wife got and i
was like uh what is this now we're never
going to be able to get trash bags like
oh it's before that yeah but i'll tell
you what dude
class yeah simple human
big
it fits perfect around the rim of it
i mean i imagine everything in the house
now it's very tight you keep everything
clean you got nice stuff all that kind
of stuff
yeah but like like i was saying i've had
a hole in my wall for two months because
my son was danging around in a in an
office chair but we're gonna get the
house painted so like we're gonna you
know it's okay i'm gonna fix it yeah
okay a couple of things you wash your
fruit
no
never uh blueberries all the time yeah
so i lied i don't eat you really eat
fruit
i thought of an apple when you said that
for some reason i'm allergic to apples i
don't eat apples or banana i'm peeling a
banana how do you feel about mayonnaise
i like it
miracle whip or helmets helmets good man
yeah i don't i've heard this question
before i don't think miracle whip is
actual mayonnaise [ __ ] garbage yeah
it's not right what's it called it's
like dressing or something yeah it's a
salad salad spread or something bread
it's got a weird verbage to it uh will
you get the express lane at a
supermarket with too many items also
where are you shopping now what's
supermarket
we are uh
an instacart family
which i can't recommend enough you tip
the insta cart guy that's probably all
done on the thing you don't get more
cash right no yeah it's all it's all in
the app yeah um we have not gone food
shopping in probably two and a half
years really it just shows up yeah and
you actually wind up saving money
because you're not buying dumb [ __ ]
walking you're not in there just [ __ ]
and they can bring it down yeah they
bring it to you it's all logged in there
you bought this last time yeah this is
yeah you just go in and reorder you used
to work for a guy i had to do it for him
where's the family vacations now
where are you taking the kids we're
going to california okay in a couple of
weeks
they're all different i do kind of wish
we had like a set thing but we did go to
california two years ago when i was on
ellen i brought them out there we stayed
in malibu nice um
they loved it i mean they love going
anywhere okay they just love us and we
love them it's like wherever we go it's
great we're having a good time yeah hmm
have you ever worn a fedora
no
i i i do and i'm trying one of those
jeff caps like the little cabbie hats
yeah i was just gonna say i i will
sometimes i know everyone like makes fun
of rogan for wearing those
and he does look you know whatever i
mean sometimes i feel like i look good
in it sometimes i don't i know sometimes
i feel like i'm in shape sometimes i
don't it depends on how cold it is and
how pale i am what kind of jacket i'm
wearing you know
anybody in your family extended family
live near a cemetery
i
i don't know i don't think so that's
just my cousins used to live right
across from one in bridesburg and i'm
scared
i would not look out the [ __ ] left
side of the house he's like yeah there's
always parking right by the cemetery i'm
like of course
leaving my car to get [ __ ] you got
magnets on the fridge
no i don't even think our fridge will
receive magnets uh was it cardboard
no i like this one it's a steel fridge
but the side will take magnets the front
won't take magnets it's like it won't
let you be trashed the whole thing is
too nice
we got a viking saab what are you doing
here it's uh it's one it's it's one of
the three it's not a viking it's not a
sub-zero it's uh you know what it is
yeah i can't think of it though it's not
a ge no no it's one of them it came with
that it came with the house it was they
were all matching we have like the
double decker oven nice the fridge that
gas stove or fought like uh electric
electric stove
but it's not coils right it's the glass
ones that the whole thing lights up yeah
i actually like ceramic ceramic yeah
yeah okay yeah
not bad you have a big thing of gum in
your car
oh dude i got so much gum okay so much i
order from amazon now that's wild who
orders amazon
um i ordered so much gum from amazon i
mean i have a closet full of gum do you
know the acronym bogo
yeah buy one get one do you do you eat
anything
[Laughter]
everybody's been to payless what the
[ __ ] uh do you eat fast food
very very rarely if you did what are you
getting
um
is chipotle fast food
no that's pretty classy that's pretty
good you're talking about like taco bell
burger king wendy's mcdonald's like that
big mac's out of maple syrup you know
[Laughter]
have you ever worn pants that zip into
shorts
yeah i mean i think i started another
trend yeah you definitely have had
breakaway pants on before well i worked
at abercrombie in uh 1999.
right around that time they made the
documentary about it you're not doing
yourself any favors of your big guy i
wasn't the hot one though i wasn't like
the kid with no shirt on no shirt on in
the front i was like the like seven out
of ten guy who was like put him in the
back he's fine but like we're not don't
put him out front he can work here but
he's in charge of the socks yeah
sticking back there and they used to
have these pants that zipped off and i
just zipped off the back half so my
calves would show oh my god and i went
to nassau community college and then
two weeks later everyone was [ __ ]
doing that it was the weirdest thing
i've ever seen i could peg you as like a
capris guy too when they were big in the
early 2000s i tried it it didn't work
for me so
is that where you went to college was
nassau county community i went to nassau
community college then i went to
university of maryland and then i
graduated from farmingdale yeah
i got expelled from university of
maryland it's pretty good though it's a
good school to get expelled from yeah
yeah very good like how dirtbag you are
like oh you got in yeah
you wear a turf all right hey as long as
you can wear the sweatshirt who gives
this [ __ ] yeah what i'm saying
chicken wing the drum or the flat i
don't eat wings
yeah i don't i don't want
the bone that close to the meat ever
in any situation
that's interesting and i eat a lot of
meat i mean i eat chicken you know those
guys will walk around the tupperware
just like grilled chicken yeah yeah i
used to be not so much anymore i can
like
i can function
without
my meals you know what i mean i do like
my structure but um what'd you have for
breakfast this morning
i had i just ate a cliff bar on the way
out at the house usually it's oatmeal
with peanut butter in it okay
cold or hot
uh hot hot hot yeah so you make it at
the house and then a monster energy okay
yeah the white kind jesus yes that comes
with a pair of white oakleys
yeah he's trying i know what to tell you
he's [ __ ] trash you might be the
longest
bag on this show to be 100
straight down the [ __ ] line garbage
and i gotta tell you i'm [ __ ] here
for it the best thing about you is you
got into the university of maryland
before you were kicked out i mean that's
wild that whole [ __ ] tale is wild
yeah which tale yours all of them what
do you mean really i mean i listen to a
lot of episodes i'm the trashiest person
but you're you're up there man you've
you've checked all the boxes every box
yeah great there's no decision of like
well maybe whatever you're in
you know the category of 100 trash yeah
i mean you're a one percenter i can tell
you that
[Laughter]
you're a one percenter i'm glad to be an
elite something buddy you are well
listen bro i [ __ ] make memes for a
living what did you think i was gonna
have come from
harvard law yeah like i you know francis
ellis of course
he was on my podcast years ago and he i
i
at my sats i did okay on right it's okay
i did i got an 1180. not bad
but there was a box that you had to
check in the forms that allowed the
s.a.t board to send your scores out to
different colleges yes
i didn't check the box because i didn't
i was like [ __ ] you send them if you
want i don't give a [ __ ] i mean i read
the box i read the question and
everything i just didn't fill out the
box i was like they'll figure it out
i remembered me i remember specifically
thinking like they'll figure it out um i
didn't give consent so francis was
talking to me and
i was on my podcast and he went to
yell
yell or harvard i can't remember i
believe he went to yale um
his family went to harvard he went to
yale or vice versa and i i told him that
story and he goes uh
oh i uh he goes i set my s.a.t scores
out to all the colleges with my
application and i was like
he goes yeah i go yeah i wouldn't know
how to do that he goes didn't you have
like an advisor at school and i was like
yeah
and he [ __ ] lost his gym teacher he's
like we came from such different
backgrounds dude like our upbringings
could not have been of course more
difficult your advisor was also the
driving teacher uh i was jojo
who drove the driving teacher car full
time as his [ __ ] main mode of
transportation listen my parents were
trying to keep us alive
and and and i was
watching
uh
[ __ ] literally
mtv raps uh bet late night uncut stand a
full-frontal comedy with dom herrera and
joe rogan in 1992 1993
and he was getting good advice from his
parents about how to get into college
six bagels for dinner
with butter and american cheese melted
on them and he was getting fed
vegetables i'm sure yeah or something
dude not the same way i mean i was in
college and my dad was trying to
convince me to get out and join the
steam fitters
like what are you going to do work at an
entry level position get a get join join
a union yeah you want to take the test
join the union get some [ __ ] bennies
yeah i didn't have there was no like
you could go on to be president
yeah we would we would get into
arguments in the house me and my my
sister and like we wouldn't ever talk
about what we argued about one of us
would just sneeze and someone would say
god bless you and that's how we'd start
talking again
of course yeah yeah that would break the
ice
100 percent thanks sinatra ladies and
gentlemen we [ __ ] love you anything
you want the folks out there to know
away anything the game check out right
here check out the game i am trash yes
you are and you've i mean you know who
he is you've seen his work of course
it's wild you're [ __ ] killed
the game in 30 seconds just real quick
please i think it's the best board game
ever made objectively obviously because
i have no attachment to it um
it's based on the instagram account
influencers in the wild where the crew
the content creators are the content
it's just a silly [ __ ] account where
we kind of have fun with the other angle
of the content
on the game if you want to turn it
around on the board
you travel around you go to bali you go
to coachella you go to burning man
whatever
that's a good time you end up at the
pink wall which is the end in los
angeles which is the influencer mecca of
course and along the way you rack up
followers instead of money so if you
land on uh no wi-fi spot you lose a turn
if uh
come on man that's just [ __ ] fun
and automatic loss of some old tweets
resurfaced
so if you land on a blue spot that's
when the random cards are pulled you
have rewards penalties challenges and
questions one of the penalties is a
problematic tweet of yours from seven
years ago is pulled up when you get
cancelled
another penalty is your dad found your
only fans lose 25 000 followers
questions rewards penalties challenges
it's a [ __ ] blast yeah it really is
as far as like now goes 2022 it's the
game of life for
people who are alive now yeah good
talking good stuff tank thank you so
much for coming in buddy thanks for
having me we absolutely love you kippy
what do you got for him uh check out one
of the live shows the tickets are moving
very very comfortably just got an update
so act now don't wait especially those
shows in philly rhode island
boston seattle portland they're all
going so get those tickets gang we love
you we'll see you next week